because Saoirse Ronan you all's you want
a really good prize what did you win I
won a trip to Florida when I was a kid
how you want it I will I won it when I
was when I was a kid and I had never
entered into a competition like that
before and it was the first day of the
summer holidays when I was I was like 9
or 10 or something and Jeri Ryan who you
know was this very well-known Irish DJ
at home he's passed away now but he was
really incredible and his show was like
the top shell in the country and Shrek 2
had just come out that's how long ago
was and he was given away this holiday
to Florida and what you had to do was
you had to phone in as one of the
characters and Shrek 2 and tell the jury
why you deserved the holiday and I
haven't started properly acting yet at
that stage or anything dad was an actor
so it was around sort of like you know
improvisers and things like that and I
was like you should go in first just why
not we had never been on like a proper
holiday God okay so we got a little
notepad like tiny little notepad and we
wrote down like a tiny little script of
what I was gonna say just the short
little script and they got on and I
think I was one of the first kids on and
I and I did it as the gingerbread man
and and so then five days later he he
found up and told me that
well you were on The Late Late back in
Ireland they found this clip so this is
this is two little clips put together
this it's your gingerbread man
yeah followed by which I read like your
reaction to winning is very squeaky
voice now Saoirse is ten years of age
now which character of you chosen
oh my I need a holiday well I've got
news for you you're going to Florida
Jamie Dornan hello
now you don't sleep eat sleep eat you
don't sleep eat no no but you do
sleepwalk listen I I that I'm aware of
I've slept once in my life I was about
11 or 12 I will go I've told some
shockers on this show before I woke up
and my dad was at the end of my bed and
he said morning Jimmy does morning you
said your man willing to tell me said
not really slept look well you said do
you think you slept last night
not usually do that so I thing is them
well someone's done a poo in the bath
[Laughter]
transoid by a sort of the process of an
elimination my sister's working his way
down the hole we met Brad fish rice Zee
at the BAFTAs I think it was um he came
over and he was we were having a chat
about something or other and he was very
nice and I introduced him to Dawn and
they shook hands and then we kind of
kept on talking and then he started to
talk him to somebody else or whatever
and then after a while I looked down and
I realized that she was still holding
two of his fingers I was like we better
go to our seats okay and she said
forty-one seconds
I said what hello guy held him for weeks
after those kind of awards bitter and um
I'm Bradley Cooper was there very nice
guy very kind of personable yes who
that's home and we were leaving she was
getting her phone out of her bag and I
noticed something sparkling in it I
realized that she had stolen his fork
she was gonna auction it for charity or
something but every now to get on home
[Music]
hard to feel like a sex symbol when your
wife is using another I feel too great
you fight your beauty and you often use
the medium of hair to fight you all have
some of the worst hairdos in film to
really know genuine like a vampire
magazine did top 10 worst hairdos and
film I'm definitely free of those like
Horrible Bosses is intentional and
that's one of the three homes talking
about movie I love home at the end of
the world
thanks it's just such a good movie and
you're so good in it however that's
having hampered I feel I mean that's a
testament I oughta mess I was at the
time that I actually stood in front of a
camera with that this one in Alexander
which there's worse pictures they're not
from Alexander that's actually not bad
that was my Doris Day look you're so not
a blonde I mean it did seem a big
decision to make
Alexander famously blonde he was
famously blondie a golden lock two
golden lock child but I'm should have
been he should have been brunette sure
maybe she shouldn't have had an Irish
accent from the 7000 reviews I read
hi-yah what's your name my name is
Eileen Eileen
yeah I'm guessing with Marlon I am from
Gerry Gerry up for the north of the
country
okay and you live they were here story
here I live over there oh wait what are
you doing
costume design awesome interpretation
okay there will be subtitles on Friday
yeah but I know ya know so far you're
not missing anything
costume interpretation yeah it's like
costume design isn't it fancy fancy
it's fancier Frank okay off you go
right so lead-up to Christmas I was back
home and did you get any of it Chris
something about Christmas yeah Christmas
that's the only good detail so far just
pick out words you'll follow the story
say bla bla bla Christmas bla bla bla
home to the shop and I had to get milk
and bread
[Applause]
so I was like rollin all right get the
groceries let's go to my boyfriend's
dewlap and just pack me up nuni they
park the car so as planned
iq boy you know perfect attainment
silver people carrier just casually
drift by casual speed so without
hesitation I spread the cross when we
look we made groceries jump in the back
of the car screaming and dump in the
back of the chair show them but taking a
mind games Christmas and I had like a
scarf up here
which was my boyfriend turned out to be
this middle-aged like I don't need to
your sound effect will shove it in
somewhere else my company gonna do it
either but
[Applause]
okay here's the music
[Music]
okay okay we can't see you now
I think you're one Gary Numan an
influence for Walter of the robot
[Applause]
okay everyone ready take it away
[Music]
[Applause]